[موسيقى]
الهوايه منذ الصغر يعني بتنشا انه كنت بحب
الحيوانات بشكل عام يعني الحيوانات بشكل
عام عندي حب لها وتوجه لها وبربي شغلات
ثانيه غير الحمامه يعني بس بركز اكثر على
الحمام متواجده شبه اليومي عند الحمام
يعني وقتي وفراغي بقضيه مع الحمام يعني
اذا مش مسافر بكون عند عند الحمام هوايه
ومتعه يعني زي ما تحكي بتكوني انت
وحماماتك لحالك وما في حدا حواليك ولما
تشوفي الحمام بتحمم وبنبسط وفي مرحله
التزاوج الذكر بالحق الانثى يعني حاجه
جميله جدا والوانها
زهيه وبتشوفي لما يطلع فراقه كمان يعني
مرحله سعيده بالنسبه لالي لما عنده فرق
وقاعد بطعمي فيه بكون مبسوط معي يعني
صراحه الحمام مش من الطيور اللي هو من
الطيور الداجنه وليس من الطيور الاليفه
يعني خلاص متعود على مكان فخلاص بعتبره
هذا مكان لانه اكله وشربه يعني موجوده هون
فرخ الصغير اللي احنا بناكله بايدنا ببين
انه اليف لفتره قصيره وبعدين خلاص لما
يتزوج ويعتمد على نفسه بنسى بنسى اللي
ربوه زي ما يعني الانسان او بنسى اهله
[موسيقى]
ففي انواع كثيره بالنسبه
للحمام الزينه
التنوع كبير مثل ما انتم شايفين من ضمن
الاشياء واللي قليل راح تلاقيها هون
بالاردن اللي هو هذا
هاوس حمامه ضخمه
جميل جدا يعني هذا اخواننا في ليبيا
يرغبوه كانوا بشكل كبير بشكل كبير جدا
يعني حمامتهم رقم واحد كانت في ليبيا
من طيور الزينه زي ما انتم شايفين
سراويل وشكل غير عن الحمام الاعتيادي ذيل
فوق راس راجع الى الخلف
كمان انا بشتغل على لون اللي يكون لون
اصفر او احمر كتف ابيض يعني هاي شغلات
نادره هذا بسموه طير سيلفر طير مشهور جدا
في الاردن عندنا حاليا يعني هاي طير يسمى
الادراغون
اهلنا في فلسطين بيحبوا الدراجون في
الفتره الحاليه مش عارف برضو كمان شو
الاسباب بس من الطير الجميله والذكيه جدا
يعني عنده كمفره في الانف وسع في جفن
العين من الطيور الجميله قريب من طير
الزاجل لكن بالشكل يختلف هاي من الطيور
الشاميه
اللي في الاردن مرغوبه في بلاد الشام بشكل
عام اللي هو البغدادي وزي ما حكيتنا
الانواع والالوان تتعدد
والاشكال تتعدد وهذه هوايه يعني او شغف
على برنامجكم شغف منذ الصغر يعني الواحد
بيكبر بتكبر معه الهوايه وبتزيد حتى مش
بتقل
[موسيقى]
في بعض الحمام مثل ما نحكي في الطيور هذه
او البودابست اذا بنلاحظوا هناك الاسود
بحاجه الى الى في حاله الانتاج بحاجه الى
ما يسمى يعني الاهالي
اللي بالتبني اللي هم بتبنوا اولادهم
يعني اسبوع زمان
اسبوع زمان عشر ايام بالكثير بنزل على
الارض هنا وبصير ياكل مثله مثل باقي
الحمامه بنفسه ببلشوا اهله يعودوه ويطعموه
[موسيقى]
يحبوا كثير يعني وطلعوا كميه الحمام اللي
عندي عندي كم حمام كبير يعني مستورد من
اوروبا من المانيا من بلجيكا من هولندا من
هنغاريا حتى من امريكا وكندا بنستورد
انواعها معنى الحمام يعني اول حاجه بنعرف
فيه انه سلام يعني
سلام الحمامه من الا
شياء على طول يعني
سلام فهو بالفعل لما تقعد عند الحمامات
بتحسي في نوع من الطمانينه وانت تراقبي
فيه يعني بتهدي انت وياه يعني هو كمان
هديل الحمام يعني من الاصوات الجميله جدا
[موسيقى]